اعلنت الشرطه الالمانيه ان سبعه اشخاص على
الاقل قتلوا في عمليه اطلاق نار وقالت
وكاله الانباء الالمانيه ان الهجوم وقع في
مركز طائفه دينيه مسيحيه معروفه باسم شهود
بمدينه همبرجر وقالت الشرطه انها تقود
عمليه امنيه في بورستيل وانها لا تستطيع
ترجيح ملابسات العمليه ولا ما اذا كان قد
نفذها شخص واحد ام اكثر
انضم الينا من برلين الصحفي اسكندر الديك
اهلا بك سيد اسكندر هل توفرت لديك معطيات
اكثر حول هذه العمليه
الواقع لا توجد معلومات اكثر بكثير مما
ذكرت للتو ولكن هنالك بالطبع الان
جاوب من الخوف والفزع خاصه في المنطقه
التي وقعت فيها هذه الحادثه وهو كان تجمع
في الواقع لشهود يهوه وهو تنظيم ديني الا
انه في الواقع منبووز عمليا من الطوائف
المسيحيه الاخرى على اعتبار انه ايضا لا
يعتبر انه يعني تنظيم مسيحي
باعتبار انه شهود يهوى هم يقصدون القبول
او الاعتراف
التنظيمات المسيحيه المعهوده المعروفه
يعني ولكن هنالك طبعا بعض المعلومات التي
جاءت من الشرطه بان
الاجواء الحاليه حاليا متفاجئه نسبيا ولكن
كان هنالك اطلاق نار من اكثر من شخص واحد
من جماعه شهود يهوه يبدو على بعضهما البعض
خلال صلاتهم او خلال تجمعهم هناك
وقتل على الاقل سته اشخاص وهنالك جرحه
ايضا
ومن يعني هناك تخوف من
اطلاق النار يستمر ايضا في امكنه اخرى ذهب
اليها هؤلاء
وبالتالي ليست الصوره غير واضحه كيف ستطور
الامور ولكن طبعا الشرطه هناك تحاول
والقوى الامنيه تحاول احاطت الموقع وعدم
ترك الامور على غريبها شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
اسكندر الديك الصحه في حدثنا من برلين